The geography cone is a species of predatory
sea snail that has particularly potent venom
indigenous to the reefs of the Indo-Pacific,
and it's the most deadly of over 500 species
of cone snails. There is no known anti-venom,
and treatment includes simply keeping someone
alive until the toxins wear off. It has been
nicknamed the "Cigarette Snail" because its
believed that a person stung by one would
have enough time to smoke a cigarette before
dying.
What The FAK: The facts and knowledge on Deadly
Animals.
A single bite delivered by the Inland Taipan
can kill up to 250,000 mice and has strong
enough venom to kill 100 adult men, and it
has has the ability to kill someone within
45 minutes.Found in Australia, it claims
the top spot as the most venomous snake, but,
luckily, it's shy, making human bites nearly
non existent. Hospitals equipped with anti-venom
have kept the death toll to zero known deaths
from this particular snake, nicknamed the
"Fierce Snake" because of the potency of the
venom, and not the behavior.
The Stonefish is one of the most venomous
fish known in the world. They are found in
the Indo Pacific Ocean but can also be found
in Florida and the Caribbean. It has thirteen
stout spines in the dorsal fin which can inject
a highly toxic venom that causes intense pain,
tremendous swelling, temporary paralysis and
even death if not treated quickly. They are
able to live out of the water for up to 24
hours and they blend into the background often
looking like an encrusted rock or lump of
coral so they are commonly stepped on making
stonefish anti venom the second most administered
in Australia.
The Tsetse Fly is a bloodsucking fly found
in Africa that transmits the parasite causing
what is commonly known as Human Sleeping Sickness.
It can drink twice its weight in blood at
every meal, and once an infected fly bites
you the infection quickly spreads through
your blood. It is fatal if untreated and between
300 and 500,000 people are estimated to suffer
from the disease. The flies are hard to control
and, unlike most biting flies where only the
female feeds on blood, both males and females
are blood suckers.
The Box Jellyfish developed its powerful venom
to instantly stun and kill prey so their struggle
to escape wouldn't damage the delicate tentacles.
It has venom considered to be among the most
deadly in the world, and it is said to be
so painful that many victims die from going
into shock and drowning after being stung.
They are found primarily in the coastal waters
off northern Australia and throughout the
Indo Pacific. Each tentacle has around 5,000
stinging cells and, depending on the location
of the sting, can cause severe symptoms, including
cardiac arrest. Vinegar is said to inactivate
the remaining stinging cells left in the skin,
and many Australian beaches have a bottle
stored on the beach next to warning signs.
The Box Jellyfish has a tiny relative found
in the same area that causes severe pain and
is nearly invincible. Called Irukandji, the
name refers to any species that causes the
same symptoms- the exact amount of species
that can cause them is still unknown. Though
it is not as deadly as the larger Box Jellyfish,
the pain is excruciating and there is no anti-venom.
Symptoms include lower back pain, muscle cramps,
sweating, nausea, and can last up to a week.
Many patients require large doses of morphine
to get them through the pain, but there are
actually few known deaths from these little
guys.
The Brazilian Wandering Spider held the Guinness
world record for "Most Venomous Spider" in
2007, and is still believed to hold that title.
They originated in Brazil but are found throughout
South and Central America. Brazilian Wandering
Spider is actually a generic name for eight
species that belong to the same genus. It
wanders all over the place searching for prey
and does not wait in ambush like a majority
of spiders. It is not afraid of humans, and
shows a defensive posture by standing on its
back legs and will attack when needed. Its
bite can be one of the most excruciating of
all spider bites because it has very large
fangs. Oh yeah, it also causes men to have
long lasting and painful erections.
The Blue Ringed Octopi are tiny and the most
deadly of all cephalopods. Their common name
comes from the bright blue rings that come
to life when threatened. Though humans are
rarely bitten, there is no anti-venom and
life-saving efforts have to be put into place
until the toxins wear off. If bitten you'll
feel nauseous, possibly go blind, lose sense
of touch, speech, and the ability to swallow,
and within 3 minutes paralysis sets in and
your body goes into respiratory arrest. Constant
CPR is needed to keep the heart pumping until
the body is able to breath on its own. And
it carries enough poison to kill 26 adults...So...don't
touch it.
Before the advent of the anti-venom the Black
Mamba bite was 100% fatal. Most snake's venom
travels slowly through the blood allowing
time for them to get treatment, but the Black
Mamba venom starts within 20 minutes and can
be fatal in only six hours. They are found throughout
most countries in sub Saharan Africa, can
reach up to 14 ft in length, and travel up
to 12 MPH. They generally avoid humans, but,
if threatened, they are fast, highly aggressive,
and often raise a third of their bodies off
of the ground, then strike repeatedly if the
attacker persists.
The creature that causes the most deaths among
humans is pretty small, really annoying, and
not nearly as intimidating as the others.
The Mosquito causes millions of deaths world-wide
every year from transmitting malaria, yellow
fever, encephalitis, and west nile virus.
I'm gonna leave you with this Scorpion, considered
one of the deadliest in the world, whose toxins
are being used to fight brain cancer.
Before we go, here's last video's winner.
Be sure to subscribe for more Vsauce2 and,
as always, thanks for watching.